hey let me do something that I think
might be interesting for some people in
the audience we've talked on the show
sort of like in general about whether
people's politics change over time
there's a stereotype that people become
more conservative as they get older
although it doesn't appear to be true
what what the reality of the situation
seems to reflect is that at any given
point in time those who are older at
that time are more conservative than
those who are younger but there is not
evidence that people become more
conservative as they get older and
there's been this sort of funny
criticism of me lately from some
enclaves of the left that I'm a
neoliberal centrist moderate of some
kind I'm not really a progressive lately
it's coming a lot from the sort of tulsi
gabbard wing of the left sometimes from
the sort of pro-assad wing of the left
there's some other enclaves that love to
tweet to me and email me and comment on
our YouTube videos that I used to be
left and now I've sort of become this
centrist neoliberal shill or whatever
and it's kind of amped up over the last
two years but particularly over the last
six months so let's figure it out we've
done the political compass test multiple
times before so we actually have my
political orientation from many years
ago from two years ago and I retook the
test this morning so let's see whether
I've become more conservative more
progressive or not really changed over
the last many years of doing the show
first data point is from when I took the
political compass test back in 2012 okay
when I took it back in 2012 I scored a
minus six on the economic left-right
spectrum negative numbers are on the
left positive numbers are on the right
meaning I was pretty solidly on the Left
on the economic left-right spectrum and
I was also a minus six on the social
authoritarian libertarian spectrum
negative numbers our libertarian
positive numbers are authoritarian so
seven years ago when when I took this
test in November of 2012 I was minus six
minus six
sort of solidly
libertarian which is a pretty good way
of how I self-described my political
beliefs we then let five years ago by
and I took the political compass test
again in 2017 a couple of years ago and
from 2012 to 2017 I became more left
economically and more libertarian over
authoritarian in the sort of social
dynamics and social issues I went from
minus six to minus 6.4 on economic
left-right meaning more left and I went
from minus six to minus six point eight
on authoritarian libertarian more
libertarian over authoritarian than in
2012 more left on economic issues in
2017 than in 2012 so then we get to
where the rubber meets the road I again
took the test this morning and it turns
out that I've become even more
progressive on both the authoritarian
libertarian spectrum and the economic
left-right spectrum on economic
left-right I am now at minus six point
six three again seven years ago I was
minus six two years ago I was minus 6.4
now I am slightly more than minus six
point three and on the libertarian
authoritarian spectrum I am now minus
seven point one three again more
libertarian over authoritarian than ever
and so there's a couple things here
number one I think it's good to
accurately understand our political
beliefs and whichever test you like I've
talked about how the I side with tests
is not a good one it's very very flawed
political compass is better although it
has some flaws which I'll talk about in
a moment I have a lot of friends who had
the sort of identity in their minds of
themselves as conservative and I would
do sort of like a verbal political
compass with them where I would ask them
their positions on taxation on social
issues on economic justice whatever and
their answers on every single question
we're clearly left-wing and there's a
lot of people out there who have come up
with a sort of identity or
characterization of their politics that
is just not accurate on the issues and
unfortunately this hurts the left people
are much more
left then they believe themselves to be
when you ask people about so many issues
like health care taxing the rich to
reduce inequality so on and so on
there's a disconnect between people's
views on the issues and how they sort of
identify politically and I think it's a
really important thing to understand
what your politics are and so one thing
that is good is that I seem to have a
relatively accurate assessment of what
my politics are now there are some
problems with this test okay number one
I don't believe that the test has really
changed almost at all since I first
started taking it seven years ago and
it's possible that there are just better
or more precise questions that could be
asked to ascertain what one's places on
the political spectrum there are also
just some really specific criticisms of
the questions on the test there are some
loaded questions on political compass
there are sort of very black-white
framings for issues that really require
more nuance so like one of the questions
on the test is abortion when a woman's
life is not threatened should always be
illegal the use of the word always makes
it difficult to really answer the
question the way most people think of
the issue so like that's an example of
how some of the questions are not
necessarily the best questions and I
could give you other examples of that
but overall I think it's good that this
test has sort of a matrix rather than
just left-right it assesses your place
on the economic political spectrum and
also whether you have a tendency towards
libertarianism or authoritarian is
authoritarianism and I guess you know
for everybody saying David you've become
a centrist shill over the years it's
quite the opposite I feel as though I am
more progressive than ever and at least
the political compass test seems to bear
that out the I side with tests is so off
the rails that it straight up had me as
sharing socialistic beliefs with kirsten
gillibrand who of course isn't a
socialist and I'm not a socialist so
that I don't think that's a good test
political compass isn't bad and if you
have other sort of questionnaires that
will put you on the political spectrum
that you think are
better than political compass by all
means send it to me and I'll do it and
I'll let you know what my what my
results are